[Music]
everyone's been talking about you and
wade
you're saying you tossed his salad i
mean i've never even
heard of dressing someone salad
we were only gone for like a minute yeah
it's long enough for wait
you are here as a part of god's plan
his spirit moved each of you to sign up
for this retreat
[Music]
hi alice right yeah welcome
[Music]
it's okay if you think things are
totally weird
i'm gonna need your cell phone and watch
you won't be needing a watch this week
in any way because
you're on jesus's time see ya
alice's retreat isn't gonna do you any
favors if you're not honest
so have you ever felt turned on
[Music]
i bet you actually did toss weight salad
i don't even know what that means oh my
god quit the act
you've got mail i am friends with a
pervy psycho
then i'm all wet calm down gable not
that wet yeah
[Music]
you know the truth is nobody knows what
they're doing
any more than the rest of us what are
you doing
we're all hiding stuff
all kinds of stuff your body is a gift
from
god you need to honor it
everybody say jesus christ jesus christ
[Music]
you